this is the Shmo with the pro we got a
Polly show it right next to me nice to
see you man hi nice to see you smell
with the dough with the pro oh with the
pro aren't you a pro or are you just a
bro
I'm with you bro but we don't know we
don't know just go with the flow yeah
okay you want some Mo no I'm cool
bring back the other guy
talk to me for a second man we're here
for a fight companion we're watching UFC
it seems like you've never seen a fight
and you're putting an entire life for
the blow here you go here we go
yeah
chunky cookie Cokey bro I went to the
line right here and then all right Hey
listen it's not to pay you can touch all
you want you got a quarter foreign